the first days of nebula we thought everything was gone
water
for the post after the impact after the bomb yes
ready to go on the motor and then thank
God
for
51 manicures and blows to the rest
and just sat down and the body of who we are from here
pit petreska
from the shock it was rockets an hour or so they were
whether such
two planes were
I here objects would have deserved a
total here you can paste.
then the kitchen robots, first of all,
judge for yourself will be our
goal of this, then
before the ruins
here I was alone in the room there were
icons chasing typos like this and on the
likes to stay alive man lamoda
we fall